Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
In this introductory episode of the podcast, we just want to take some time to explain
what's going on here at Riker Medical.
We'll start with a review of how we got here.
We'll explain where things are at and how this podcast fits into the picture.
We'll paint a vision of what we hope this project to become and then we'll end it with
a discussion about how you can get involved.
Riker Medical started with a book on ventilator management for pre-hospital folks.
We self-published that resource to help clinicians in the field gain a basic understanding of
ventilators and transport.
The idea from the beginning was to make that a free resource for everyone.
We got set up as an LLC and started the webpage to have a place to host it.
You can access and download that book for free.
Just head over to RikerMedical.com and navigate to this section on vent management.
Once we had the website started, we slowly began to add other bits of content there,
various resources for clinicians in the field.
We've got some drug references, examples of protocols, cheat sheets, that sort of thing.
There's lots more in the works, but it takes time and we got distracted by another idea
that brought us to where we are now.
The thought struck us that there are lots of people out there working in the field that
have insight to offer, but there's not a good way for those motivated individuals to share
what they know without a lot of upfront effort to make it happen.
Our vent book, for example, has been out for over a year now and the reach we've been able
to achieve is pretty limited.
That seems unfortunate as we imagine there are great many medics and nurses out there
who would be stoked to come across this type of thing.
Our solution for that is to try and use this platform, which is slowly gaining attention,
to allow others to publicize what they have to offer to the greater community.
Taking that idea one step further, we thought it'd be pretty rad to make it happen via a
continuing education exchange.
We could build out a CE program to give hours back to people who contribute their work.
The idea is to foster some sense of community that both provides valuable content and gives
a benefit back to those who do the work.
Of course, we want the thing to be free.
Now if you follow us on social media, you may already know that we did get granted organizational
accreditation for a CE program through CAPSIE.
That's the Commission on Accreditation for Pre-Hospital Continuing Education.
Unfortunately and for a variety of reasons that we don't need to get into, CAPSIE has
revoked that accreditation until we add a few more pieces to the puzzle and resubmit
our application.
That's where we're at for now.
This podcast will eventually be part of that CE program.
Listeners will be able to pitch ideas to us for episodes.
We will work with them to make it happen and then CE credit will be awarded in the exchange.
In addition, there will be an option for the community at large to get credit for listening
to certain episodes and taking quizzes or some sort of competency assessment that accompany
those episodes.
For now, we don't have the capacity to award credit, but we are still looking for content
contributors to work with us through the process so that we can demonstrate to CAPSIE exactly
how the quality control aspects work on our end.
So if you're interested in that sort of thing, here's how it would happen.
Head on over to rightgormedical.com, follow the links to the ConEd program development
page and submit an activity application.
You will review that application and then get back to you on next steps for making it
happen.
In the meantime, we here at Riker Medical have a few ideas for episodes and will try
to contribute regularly to the show.
Now, it is worth noting that not all of the stuff we host on the show or on the website
fall into the CE program.
We may choose to share things that are non-clinical or otherwise non-testable and therefore can't
really be worked into the continuing education side of things.
So the show will be a mix of both.
That said, if you have an idea for an episode that probably won't meet criteria for the
CE program, we're also game for that as well.
You can use the very same application to get in touch and we'll take it from there.
As far as what sorts of things fall into the CE model, that takes a bit of explaining.
Our initial pitch to CAPSIE included seven activities.
First are the podcast and blog, which are pretty self-explanatory.
We'd give credit to folks for contributing episodes or posts.
We also envisioned a mentorship activity in which we could give credit to an experienced
clinician for building out a mentorship program for someone new to the field or with less
experience.
Then there was the idea of annotated illustrations, offering credit for explaining concepts visually
or graphically.
We also had a reflection activity in which someone could share an experience via the
platform in an active reflection or debrief, whether that be text, audio, or video.
Another idea was the critique, essentially a way for someone to informally peer-reviewed
content produced by someone else and to provide constructive feedback on whatever it might
be.
Lastly, was the instructional design activity in which we give credit to people for building
out courses or lessons.
The hope moving forward is to find a way to make all of these activities work.
The catch is that we now also have to have a mechanism to offer the community at large
the opportunity to earn credit for participating in or consuming whatever content we put out
through the CE program.
Just to be clear, this is at the request of CAPSIE as the accrediting body, so there's
no real workaround for us there.
The plan is to get content up on a learning management system or LMS so that anyone can
access those final projects and participate in them for credit, which is cool.
That means that we'll eventually have a library of stuff to meet whatever CE needs you might
have.
The downside or the problem to be overcome is that not all of these activities we initially
envisioned are readily testable.
So let's say you want to do a reflection on a run you had and how it affected you personally.
That's not something that lends itself to educational goals or learning outcomes that
we could put down on a lesson plan for others to get credit from, which is totally okay
and we're still down to host your story.
It just means that we've got to sort out which contributions will be part of the CE
program and which will be just for the sake of getting it out there into the universe
and sharing the experience.
Another problematic example is the mentorship program.
It's a bit tough to test outsiders on a one-on-one mentorship session.
That said, we can work to design those plans to focus on specific goals or objectives.
We could then record those sessions and share via the LMS like any other asynchronous course.
In fact, there's also the option to live stream them so that participants can get credit
in real time.
In that scenario, we'd be able to give credit to the mentor for developing and guiding the
session, to the live audience for participating synchronously, and then to the stragglers
who watch it asynchronously via the LMS.
We've been toying with this idea along with some of our partners, so more on that whenever
we get it worked out.
But to summarize where things are at currently, we're going to make this CE program happen
one way or another and when we do, it'll be badass.
In the meantime, we'll work on getting this podcast and the blog going and are open to
any help we can get.
The end goal or vision for it all is that we will exist as a home for high-quality learning
opportunities created for and by a community of clinicians.
We can help hash out ideas and refine projects to meet industry standards and requirements
of accreditation, but our hope is to eventually become a host and let you guys keep the things
going.
We're here to get it all started, to do the logistics and maintain accreditation, and
then we'll probably still want to pitch in every now and again with new thoughts and
ideas as they come up.
Basically, we want to break the mold that keeps ground-level providers from pitching
in on the full-med community.
Lots of folks have stuff to offer, but not everyone has an in to make it happen.
And then oftentimes it's the case that someone has an idea in the works, but not a good way
to collaborate on and develop that idea.
That for sure was the case when we put the vent book together.
There wasn't an established mechanism to work with peers on those ideas.
Hopefully, Reicher Medical can be that supportive community for others.
We want to both give clinicians a way to contribute and support them in that effort via constructive
and cooperative approach.
And then to take that concept just a bit further, we're hoping to make the CE program as affordable
as possible.
The content development side of the house will for sure be put out for free, and all
the things we create will be openly available to anyone with a computer.
We're going to try and make the CEs that go with those things free also, but that's
dependent on a handful of factors.
So it might end up just being ridiculously cheap until we can get funding worked out.
And then there's one other part of the vision.
CAPSI is the accrediting body for EMS stuff, and that's where we're starting.
But there are also avenues to get CEs for our nursing colleagues, and there are specialty
boards that many of us use for maintenance of certifications.
We'll get there eventually, but for now it's one step at a time.
So that's the general idea.
Now you know how we got here, where things are at with us, and what we're hoping to make
happen.
Next step is how you can get involved.
First and foremost, check out the website.
You can always get in touch with us there, or on social media, or by adding comments
here, wherever you happen to be listening to this.
We are open to any and all ideas or suggestions.
But more specifically, we need to get some content up in order to resubmit our application
at CAPSI.
We've got details about that on the website, but we need examples of each of the activities
we want to include in the program, and the more the merrier.
So if any of them sound appealing to you, hit us up and we can make it happen.
We also need help figuring out exactly how to host all the things and track users in
the system.
So if you have experience working with the LMS side of things and want to share what
you know, we could use some help there too.
And then lastly, we also need people to lend a hand as content reviewers.
As activities get rolling, we have a cadre of volunteers that maintain a dialogue with
participants to offer feedback and guidance as the projects start to take form.
And then once submitted, we review them internally to make sure everything is copacetic and meets
all the standards we are held to.
If that sounds like something you're into, just let us know and we can set up a time
to discuss.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick before we go, just a few shout outs.
First is to Pragmatic Paramedics, another awesome podcast that we highly recommend.
Next is to the St. Fisher Church of Evidence-Based Medicine.
If you don't follow them already, definitely check them out.
These guys, both Pragmatic Paramedics and the St. Fisher folks, have been instrumental
in getting our stuff out there into the world and we truly appreciate that.
And then we'll end things with a shout out to my good friend Josh Pittman and his buddy
Kevin Pons.
They put the music together for the show.
Until next time.